well thank you for the the kind
introduction and uh I'll try to you know
if folks want to ask questions we're
going through since we have the time
like feel free to ask as we go along
I'll say it's it's really cool to be
able to present at this class in
particular because I guess when I was
coming up uh or I mean I remember in
grad school like generative models are
kind of this cute thing on the side I
mean of course they had their principled
applications and you know if you were
serious you did industry related super
learning and of course we've seen a
complete inversion of that in these past
few years uh and I mean it's touched
everything and now we've been you know
Society at large so when asked to talk
about science specifically it's kind of
like a daunting task even think about
like I'm sure if any of you kind of make
your way to uh nurer icml or I clear or
whatever workshops there's a ton that
are like s you know AI for blah um could
be on many different things so they're
uh today I'm going to try to focus
specifically on the role the generative
models have and kind of some of the you
know aspects of them they're they're
being probabilistic uh they're giving
you distributions to work with that
really have a role in The Sciences so
just some examples of that you know of
course are we're trying to propagate
uncertainty in complex physical systems
like I think this just came out uh like
a month ago but it was like kind of
bootstrapping these like neural weather
predictors with kind of diffusion
powered kind of forecasting for onsemble
thinking since you know chaos is
intrinsically part of these systems um
very cool that you're having uh Ben talk
right after this on the whole kind of I
I mean I I think I saw that was like on
the kind of Nerf world because there's
some extremely uh related applications
of of Nerf and kind of reconstruction
inverse problems in the physical
sciences that can actually resolve
structures and now movies of structures
down to kind of the width of an atom uh
so like Nerf through molecules lots of
really cool development there of course
in like theoretical and kind uh kind of
at the at the edge of theoretical
physics and in kind of high energy
particle physics there's kind of these
roles of can how do we have a powerful
inference machinery for detecting subtle
statistical anomalies and as we kind of
like reason at the edge of uh scientific
theory um and then you know I mean I
guess across the bay there's like new
efforts where like if if we really
uh get um sufficiently powerful agents
powered by just large scale generative
models like llms or or their descendants
uh can can we actually have uh
generative models doing science for us
and maybe they'll make this entire talk
kind of irrelevant and obsolete real
fast but um I'm not going to talk about
any of these today so uh but you know
you can I always will recommend kind of
attending uh
whichever workshop May may be relevant
to these whenever you're at a machine
learning conference um but I'm going to
talk about uh three different areas that
are let's say right at the intersection
of of actually kind of several Fields uh
you know spoil alert they all have to do
with proteins however one of the reasons
I think proteins have been so popular is
because they have a little something for
everyone both methodologically you know
kind of vision Vision folks NLP folks
structured prediction folks uh
probabilistic modeling and basan people
there's the reason for all those tools
and proteins and the data exists for
them but then also specifically let's
say in the kind of area of generative
modeling there are kind of specific
algorithmic considerations and there's
actually still a ton of algorithmic work
that needs to be done I think to push on
all these problems which is why I
thought I would try to focus on these
three with you today um to just kind of
say you know scaling is important we all
got a scale and we're all trying to
figure out a scale but there's also
really interesting I think
methodological considerations uh where
you can really impact uh science so
let's get started so um first off uh one
thing that's kind of like always on the
edge is you know we're learning
probabilistic models and and you know uh
especially these days when people think
of generative AI they think of you know
ask for something get object generate
things generate actions generate video
um but we also are learning density
models of the world and interestingly in
science there are areas where it's the
density model itself which has kind of
been alluding us in our description of
Nature and uh is kind of can help us see
things that we weren't able to see
before so I'm going to talk about that
first with genetics okay so Min problem
one here uh we have uh kind of
profoundly better abilities to read and
write uh genomes than and DNA than we
did in a long time uh so as you probably
heard I mean this is a very old but like
we're just all the governments are are
sequencing lots of genomes the UK bio
bank has been leader they kind of this
is uh an old publication now but um
we're really getting point we're going
to have millions of genomes soon and
when you look across all those millions
of genomes you know every person you
know has on the order of I don't know
like 40 30 to 50 or so you know
mutations that you know just happened
when you were uh you know kind of
brought into this world and when you add
all those up across everyone there's
just tons and tons of mutations that are
happening in people that we have no idea
how to interpret and you know sometimes
those mutations are things that have
uh never happened before on Earth or
super rare and we kind of have no idea
how to kind of sort which of them are
just noise to which of them may actually
be things we need to address and at the
same time we have new found ability to
address uh kind of genetic problems so I
mean I'm saying this at Berkeley like
you're uh of course like one of the
centers of you know Gene editing
Revolution crisper Revolution there's
also massive advances that are happening
kind of at the ability to synth syze DNA
and kind of with all of this ability to
read and write DNA the big question is
well what do you actually do with it and
and what does this genetic variation
that we're seeing in the world mean and
it's actually quite hard so uh you can
start to do things like people are
inventing High throughput experiments
that would let's say allow you to just
in a in a test tube manufacture some of
these mutations just put them in cells
or in proteins some kind of model system
see which of them are doing bad stuff
and then we can like prioritize those
for disease but that's very slow and not
kind of addressing let's say hundreds of
millions at the it's kind of not at the
hundreds of millions of variant scale
what is interestingly at the hundreds of
millions or actually you know more like
tens of billion scale is like the fact
that we've sequenced all these genomes
and we have this amazing repository of
genetic information kind of from all of
life on Earth um and this is where
likelihood comes in so it turns out we
have all these data we don't really know
you know um we humans didn't design this
data it kind of it erose through
evolutionary processes it's very non-id
it has a lot of kind of complicated
structure in it um but one thing that we
do know is that the things that are
around today the proteins DNA um the
sequences that we see were those that
survived and so in a sense you know
mutations are constantly being created
through life and but they're also being
filtered out when they break things um
or just uh kind of also Amplified
perhaps if they confer some kind of
Advantage so um and and you know you can
squint there's a bunch of reasons why
this shouldn't work there are reasons
like regimes in which you can justify
there's actually a kind of deeper
connection here but roughly speaking you
uh if you imagine that a variation is
being produced in a kind of roughly
uniformly random way then uh one
implication of that is that the distri
just the distribution of sequences
that are around today actually tells us
what those historical selective forces
were and so we can kind of see in these
data what what are these proteins
supposed to do and what are they trying
to avoid doing and kind of give us this
you know other dimension to interpret
all the DNA on Earth so this is actually
just very kind of like straightforward
statistics but we're going to you know
power it with deep generative models um
we collect a lot of data um though
actually can be super variable so here
I'm showing you proteins they can be
represented as sequences let's say like
a typical size of these data might be
that um for uh let's say you've probably
heard of hemoglobin you know we have it
birds have it fish have it it kind of
store helps move oxygen around and uh uh
our circulatory systems it's been around
a long time it's job hasn't really
changed so there are lots and lots of
versions of it this is not actually
hemoglobin I think it's a core core
metabolic enzyme um then when you look
even when you just take these sequences
let's you just them so this is very kind
of not big data this is small data you
align them maybe there's a few thousand
maybe there's tens to 100 thousand of
them there sequences that are let's say
on the order of you know 100 to 500
amino acids long uh in this 20l alphabet
um and like the first thing you can ask
is just can we try to like what
biologists noticed when they first
started sequencing DNA uh let's say 40
years ago was that when you line them up
there's like obvious p pns to the eye so
when I kind of color these amino acids
by uh physical properties you kind of
see like oh there's like these pink
columns these blue columns these have to
do with you know physical chemical
properties of them like you're you're
mentally building a statistical model of
kind of what the constraints are here
and so then the question is just what
else could we pick up so the game here
is very simple we're just going to fit
density models and see what they tell us
okay so take data learn some density
model and then we can like reason about
what the of the game are what the
selective pressures are but just looking
at likelihood ratios okay so like the
thing I said that kind of you know in
your uh in your mind you might kind of
have been doing by ey is kind of taking
these data that are aligned and mentally
seeing like well what do I see kind of
like some position specific you know uh
token like uh biased vocabulary being
used there um there's kind of like when
we talk about you know pre deep learning
you know the uh everybody loved their
graphical models Bas Nets and Mark of
random Fields um that's kind of like a
first step up when you imagine that I
have kind of sitewise factors the next
way it could go up for is that like
pairwise factors so these like the kind
of uh multi-letter version of these are
sometimes from physics called pots
models you could look at something like
that of course what here today is deep
generative models so um like what's the
like maybe simplest thing and this is
now like a blast to the Past um you know
back in the days of vaes um but even
just a very simple kind of let's say MLP
style like if these data are aligned
like no structure just like an MLP uh
vae um just trying to model patterns you
could you could uh kind of try to
capture these factors of variation with
with blatant factors and do inference on
the system so cool thing this has been
around for I don't know like six six
seven years now um people got this
ability that I mentioned earlier to make
lots of mutations uh in in the lab
measure them they can make these Maps so
this is actually an in silic predicted
map but the experimental Maps look quite
a lot like it um where essentially we
have all the positions in our protein
sequence and we in the local kind of you
know one mutant neighborhood evaluate
all possible mutations uh you kind of
see like oh look there's parts of this
protein when I if I mutate it it it just
destroys it instantly then there's parts
that are kind of super tolerant to
mutation so blue is bad dark Blue's bad
um very cool thing and I I mean when I
first saw this it was kind of wacky
because this is not like train a
foundation model and fine tune or or do
unsupervised uh learning and fine tune
this is really just like saying we're
just going to fit a density model
Evolution and does that do this the raw
likelihoods have anything to do with
what happens in the real world and they
actually do kind of surprisingly well so
you can just literally take uh what
happened in an ex in a in the lab when
people made all the mutations in a
protein uh compare them to the raw log
likelihoods or log you know log
likelihood
ratios uh and uh and get these kind of
amazing correspondences with like
frequently like you know explaining over
half the variation sometimes even in in
these experimental data uh it's actually
kind of crazy because in many cases we
can do this across totally different
proteins which had totally different
functions you know one be an enzyme its
job is to like catalyze some reaction
another could be a structural Protein
that's supposed to just bind something
and kind of be stable but all these
different functions but the interesting
thing is like we're just modeling
essentially we're building this
generative model that's trying to
capture what what is the evolutionary
generator on Earth do so what that tells
you is what was selected for
historically and so kind of function is
whatever the protein was selected to do
so kind of across lots and lots of
experiments or at least you know uh
maybe five years ago this was a lot of
experiments you can see kind of just
completely unsupervised prediction of
mutation effects um so it's kind of zero
shot uh depending on what one means by
that they're kind of different different
takes but like uh it's it's pretty cool
in that you can just take raw
likelihoods and make contact with
something that's real in the physical
world because of this connection with
Evolution um on the point of now there's
a wrinkle though so then like I mean if
you kind of saw this this is old news
the first thing you think is well okay
well there's this there's um let's say
hundreds of millions or billions of
protein sequences in the world depending
on how you count I should just train a
really really big L llm kind of on
proteins and then that's just going to
answer all these questions we move on to
another topic um one thing that already
recognize in this is that sometimes the
data around any one protein family are
kind of super narrow and this was
surprising to us because I don't know a
lot of times variational Bas is like a
cool way to do like mathy papers at
conferences but like maybe doesn't so
often find it way into kind of like
methods that are are kind of leading
empirical performance but we kind of
found it was very funny like I think
it's just because the data can be so
small you know sometimes they're just
only a few thousand sequences that
actually doing kind of a double doubly
variational vae was actually important
here um so just what I mean is like you
kind of you know vaes maybe they're most
relevant today and that they're kind of
like uh you know special case or
predecessor to diffusion models but um
uh
we were normally doing variational
inference in the latent factors but you
can also and I think it was anticipated
in the original you know uh King Mo
willium paper you can also be very
doubly variational you can be
variational on the weights at the same
time you know even just with like mean
field
posteriors uh kind of with these and
these beijan vs for some reason people
can't kick them uh so then I mentioned
the llm idea like what happens let's
just scale up let's build density models
of the whole protein Universe can we
make contact good news is you know So
Meta did some really nice work uh kind
of leading this like building these
models also Salesforce this was like the
era of kind of of tech of that doesn't
have do protein stuff like doing protein
stuff um uh that kind of really nice
work on on both of these here um and
interestingly what we found uh or so I'm
not involved in in any of this work but
um uh what the field at large has found
is kind of it we still can't shake these
these weird you know regularized one
family at a time models performance-wise
uh um so okay what I'm showing you here
we've got um the kind of classic way
where you just say I'm going to take one
protein I'll go collect its homologues
and uh build an alignment of them and
then just build one of these really
local density models with like an MLP
decoder very boring very underpowered
thing but we can't we can't of that's
what these methods are here but when we
kind of scale it up do it on the whole
genome uh human gen genome uh it's still
frequently especially when the local
data are strong actually kind of the
method that's hard to beat uh and then
even these are all you know they're not
they're still pretty big these are like
you know maybe 600 700 million parameter
LMS trained on your 100 to 250 million
protein sequences that were like pretty
non- redundant but it was like I think
it it might just say that the the
details of evolution and the selection
pressures within each family are so
detailed and specific to that one family
that kind of you actually don't share a
lot of statistical strength and kind of
learn about them too much from training
on all the other sequences so in some
ways your protein language model is as
good as it has like kind of memorized or
gotten the statistics of that one
specific family that happened to be in
there um uh and then even on the LM side
uh the kind of best method that's pure
LM at least ases of in the past couple
years um was still actually finding you
had to pull in the data somehow so they
did this kind of inference time
retrieval approach so just llm like an
LM train on all the proteins but then a
test time uh when we're trying to
compute things we still pull in an MSA
for the local family and we just do
something really simple this is not like
complex retrieval stuff but just uh like
uh mix in the kind of local first order
frequencies uh to our likelihood
estimates and kind of still bring in the
local data that way and kind of this is
uh in some sense B this kind of method
to beat so why do I kind of say all this
and then you know why do we care about
this why is this worth you know the
first chunk of this talk um this has
actually been really helpful so like the
uh there is this whole world in genetics
where there are people who go into
clinics who who like get their genome
sequenced and they have some rare
disease and they're just the clinicians
are trying to help them navigate like
what what's broken and kind of they have
to we have use computational tools to
like pre-screen like which which
mutations seem like they're broken and
kind of these are the ones that are kind
of leading leading the tip of the spear
spear here so kind of this one was
actually just the pure like train one
vae on beian VA on a family at a time
approach that's kind of out here um and
uh but I think it's kind of the fact
that it that we still can't escape this
like local data strength is kind of a
it's an interesting question makes it
seem like there's probably more uh
algorithmic and kind of methods work
here as well as kind of the scale
problem um what are few some future
directions for this uh well so just
across the bay like maybe you would have
seen a post recently kind of another big
idea is could we do like um Foundation
models on whole genomes so train let's
say like LMS not just on these one
proteins at a time so you know proteins
are sequences that are just short little
stretches and genomes like what if we
just get long context uh so actually in
this method they're not using
Transformers they're using kind of some
of the hyena Stu stuff uh and
derivatives um but we use like long
context autor regressive models and just
shove whole genomes from as many
organisms as possible uh kind of maybe
not surprisingly the very first one out
of the gates is not quite catching up
protein specific models um but you know
they're getting in the neighborhood so
this will be an interesting space to
watch um also you've probably definitely
heard of alpha folds um and I think kind
of being able to just close the gap and
like connect these data to uh structure
and kind of provide that extra level of
interpretation is another another um
kind of major Direction folks are
thinking about here um but so that was
kind of the first first chunk I just
want to say like likelihood estimation
is still has kind of sometimes like uh
Great Value and you know so if you can
get better Methods at estimating
likelihoods um they can really uh impact
our ability to understand genetics okay
so second area um uh uh which is kind of
another problem uh if we go back to the
past like kind of like generative models
have always been this very interesting
kind of the the research field in
generative models has very much been
this interesting traversal between kind
of finding models that are flexible and
tractable hey John can I jump in for a
moment please because you're done with
the first part right so maybe can have
some questions about the first part my
my question is what do you see as some
big opportunities ahead here what are
some missing pieces maybe that would be
interesting to think about oh yeah I
mean I think kind of I would this last
area is uh is one so let's kind of if we
if we thought about
genomic uh work so it's we're kind of
very much in the one protein one gene at
a time but kind of much of biology is
understood through interactions of of
genes and uh and the the interactions
are technically encoded in genomes but
kind of none of our modeling efforts
thus far are really kind of revealing
that like um even when Alpha fold has
built these databases that compute the
structures of all the proteins uh that
are out there it's usually only one
protein at a time and not but even
though most of the time many proteins
assemble into these complexes that have
kind of a whole complex molecular
machine so I would say very much kind of
scaling up to genomes thinking about
interactions uh is feels like one of the
big near-term Frontiers and some of
these do they have natural data sets to
kind of work with or does that need to
be invented as you go along it is like
very much something where probably some
of the uh barriers are you have to kind
of go and and solve the data problems
there is raw data so I mean like these
folks doing these genomic Foundation
models just scraped a bunch of them from
like kind of mainstream biomedical uh
databases uh I wouldn't there there is
not like let's say like an image net or
kind of a ready to as as ready to attack
though you can like start to look at
these papers and the data that they've
prepared um as one starting point
D yeah I mean definitely if you all have
any other questions for this uh probably
won't come back to the the genomics
part questions right now anybody
else want to wait till the
end okay oh there's a question in the
front here yeah what happens if we do
like a if you do like a next token or
like next sequence prediction with the
genes are there common
patterns uh so well I want make sure I
understood so the question is about next
token prediction so these sequences
these right here just trans like these
especially esm and
next predict the next letter uh and then
this one is that except at the scale of
whole genomes so you uh you don't you
don't just you go through one protein
and you just keep on predicting the DNA
and so you predict not just the proteins
but also the kind of regulatory elements
that sit by proteins the kind of DNA
that sits in between uh coding regions
and all of it uh as for what patterns
they pick up it's pretty cool um the
protein ones if you look at their
attention Maps the um in kind of in a
completely unsupervised and just what
emerges way basically the 3D structure
so that the contacts just appear in the
attention Maps um this has been
documented by like several several times
over with different different models and
efforts it just seems like it's the
efficient way to kind of model the
correlation structure in the data would
be kind of you know attending to the the
appropriate local dependencies um and
then like I probably yeah there are tons
of patterns that this these like genomic
LM papers start to
probe that are kind of like you know
what causes let's say a certain elements
that's involved in regulating DNA like
promoters or enhancers to appear next to
proteins it's like it's a deep rabbit
hole it's kind of very early days I
think this first one's maybe more of a
pro of concept but yeah you can look at
the paper itself to see kind of some
more of the the large scale patterns
there
I hope I I hope I had made clear like
yeah that so these are yeah these are
Transformers just on those protein
sequences
uh one more question here I guess
continuing off of that point like at
least in this class like one thing that
we've learned is like the importance of
like generation versus compression as
well like compression is a huge yeah
aspect of this is like when you're doing
these um Computing on these sequences is
there any like are you just Computing on
these like RAW Protein sequences or is
there any form of like impression you
try to do like some type of oranization
that could potentially make these sequ
is much more shorter or efficient to
generation on or is yeah
search super super interesting uh very
important question I I kind of you know
there has been efforts to try to look
into making tokenization work um I think
definitely there's kind of a bit less of
obvious super typ typical structure that
we see in kind of natural language
tokenization to Leverage and so often we
kind of do care about the token level
edits like what happens if I mutate this
letter um such that kind of the field
has really kind of struggled to jump
into like building kind of EXO like kind
of like a b even just a bite pair
encoding or kind of variable length
thing but but it kind of it does feel
like like maybe we're not squeezing all
the juice out um and that kind of more
more could be could be done there I
don't I don't have the top of the head
know of a paper that's like at it uh
kind of
conclusively but very interesting
question right thanks John let's
continue awesome awesome I want to make
sure you know the end the last section
is the like stereotypical we want
generative models that spit out complex
objects uh kind of on demand um so I
want to you know make sure we get there
um but I think there's just kind of this
likelihood thing uh it's kind of
sometimes feels like an academic uh
Pursuit when we're kind of doing
building probabilistic general of models
so it's interesting to see where it has
applications so this middle one is also
that category this is also I would say
an even more kind of nent developing
field but uh I think so so kind of like
there's an interesting challenge as you
like look through all the different
types of approaches we use in deep
generative modeling we're trying to kind
of seek models that strike a balance
between kind of uh expert expressivity
and flexibility and also
tractability um and there's always kind
of like the models that sit on weird uh
Corners let's say of all these kind of
trade-offs between these different
properties one of them is energy based
models they kind of you know I know in
the past couple years there's been kind
of renewed effort a few workshops on
them uh but it's interestingly like a
lot of them they're kind of the OG
energy based model was uh physics and
especially molecular physics and in some
ways all of the problems that we know to
be very challenging about working with
energy based models in machine learning
are also kind of like deeply illustrated
by this molecular physics problem and
you know kind of some of the questions
people have been asking like can we
learn amortized Samplers to attack you
know kind of really intractable nasty
distributions are kind of really at the
Forefront of pushing this whole area
forward so kind of here's one view it's
a little biased but uh interesting one
which is let maybe like all a good chunk
of molecular physics is literally just
an inference problem and I mean
inference in the like probabilistic
graphical model sense of like Computing
conditionals and marginals of like of
distributions not necessarily like you
know uh evaluating neural networks on on
gpus uh so um in some sense I mean this
is there's a stretch here because we're
like kind of approximating out qm and
chemistry and all that but uh in some
sense we have these descriptions of
physics that basically say if you kind
of look literally at the atoms literally
molecules you literally water and just
kind of everything's very literal the
laws of physics are actually or at least
kind of classical approximation of them
are pretty simple pretty boring and they
just have kind of a known structure uh
that has kind of some simple interaction
terms and then really you know the
objective in would be to essentially
like compute like infer things from this
like um we have a well- defined energy
function and then it induces a
distribution Over States which is just
the boltzman distribution or uh ebms as
we kind of like know them sometimes in
ml or basically just this is like an
unnormalized likelihood and uh uh the
district the states will all uh that
like a system or structure can adapt we
all just compete with each other uh
according um to this log likelihood via
the normalizing constant um but as we
know uh basically this setup is kind of
uh in that whole kind of tractability
expressivity flexibility kind of
trade-off is really in the corner where
it's extremely expressive and frequently
very intractable so kind of
sampling is hard um so maybe we could
like Express actually many distributions
very succinctly and very powerful things
for example like what if you know the
energy function is let's say kind of an
evaluation function of an NP hard
problem then uh in a sense kind of
drawing samples from from such a thing
uh kind of gives you the answer to an NP
hard problem that probably also means
that uh sampling is not is not going to
be is maybe hard in a deeper sense uh
okay but so despite this people have
still tried to ask the question well is
it actually an inference problem is it
sufficient if we go to Great expense uh
which you can do like let's say if you
were formerly uh a hedge fund manager
who kind of built a private uh computer
Fleet that can like simulate molecular
physics uh ex uh kind of extreme scales
which is precisely what uh DHA research
group does they built custom Hardware
that can just do an absurdly huge number
of time steps of these simulations and
then if you so you bring this extreme
hardware and then you focus on extremely
tiny problems very very small proteins
what you can see is that this physics
does work like it will fold proteins up
um but the kind of when you hear the
actual time stepping in this it's
actually insane so it's doing MD if
you're not familiar with MZ it's super
similar to like Len Dynamics or it has
like a thermostat but it's like not
super important it's kind of you know
doing gradient descent with noise uh or
you know deterministic noish stuff um
but uh essentially uh the typical time
step you have to simulate these systems
with is a few fem tocs but like the
shortest length of time on which
anything interesting like a fast folding
protein folds is like a microsecond and
then you know frequently uh kind of
stuff we actually care about in biology
like binding events and kind of
interesting you know this protein flips
into this position and does something
else happens on milliseconds so even
just to kind of simulate the the folding
brute force of like the smallest Protein
that's like a fast considered a fast
folder a microsecond folder is 400
million time steps and I don't know
about you but like if you've ever you
kind of think like oh if I'm doing a lot
of steps that's like a million steps so
uh you know going into to this kind of
regime it's it's it's crazy um and then
like it's also just uh you literally
would pick up you know anywhere from you
know one to three additional orders of
magnitude of complexity to of go towards
bigger things okay so all this said you
know molecular physics is a hard
inference problem um okay so then like
can we where enter deep generative
models how can they help this picture
one starting point from a few years ago
it's an interesting one is an idea of
amortized samplings so if we have like a
really hard distribution we want to draw
samples from it uh one thing we could do
is try to train another generative model
as a kind of surrogate or a proposer
into into that distribution and so
that's this idea in in in molecular
physics world something called boltzman
generators uh I don't know if you all
covered like normalizing flows uh and
kind of you know change of variable
formula based generative models but um
kind of one nice thing is they they they
let you compute like likelihood related
quantities like entropy or kind of uh
another other related things kind of
analytically or at least get you know
kind of uh uh good uh um estimators of
those quantities so um basically this is
also super similar to kind of
distillation efforts as we know them so
basically idea is we have this hard
distribution it's like some force field
it defines some distribution over Atomic
coordinates um what we're going to do
we're going to kind of build a proposal
that Maps like a kind of a white you
know whitened uh uh just standard normal
distribution via an invertible Network
into uh into uh the states that are
occupied uh by the coordinates and then
um we can kind of train this with a a
probability desolation type loss so
minimizing K Divergence which basically
um is like trying to say um make your
flow when you push your uh gausian
through this mapping make it like get
low energy things while also you kind of
maximizing entropy or kind of preserving
normalization um also if you um well
we'll come back to it but like training
these types of things is usually
annoying and kind of has instabilities
um so then um in practice because it's
annoying and has instabilities it won't
exactly match the target distribution so
then we can kind of do distributional
cleanup by using importance weights so
kind of get the ratio of what the actual
distribution is to kind of what our our
surrogate proposal is and then kind of
if we want to compute any average of
objects that are emitted by samples we
can just reweight them with the with uh
importance weights so it's it's like
sounds nice uh unfortunately in the
first versions of this it's still quite
hard um I mean people I think were
excited when it first came out um in
practice it's one of those things like a
lot of flow models there's kind of in
the supplement there's more challenges
like uh oh actually kind of to even get
the flow to train stably you kind of
have to warm start it by pre-running a
simulation and then co- Trin the
distillation loss with some some actual
samples this also means that you can't
like the real dream is could we just
amortize train a model that learns to
fold proteins from scratch just kind of
throw a ton of compute at it and we'll
learn it all from scratch but even here
it's not learning from scratch you kind
of have to already know the fold and
then initially it with wiggling around
this I saw this kind of one of a recent
like I clear submission folks continuing
to try this and basically they had a
whole section just talking about how
it's still you know training flows is
hard um but I I wanted to highlight it
because I think it's also the emti
sampling idea is super interesting it's
extremely early days it would seem
likely that you couldn't just take the
current things and scale them up there's
real kind of methodology work to be done
so if you know that's the kind of thing
that interests any of you or maybe
you're already thinking about it I think
there there's lots do here um and if we
could just let's say get instant samples
from uh from kind of molecular systems
it would really allow us to like do
really kind of incredible things in kind
of molecular design so lots of room for
further development I think super cool
uh kind of analog of like distillation
efforts that we might kind of encounter
in generative modeling um more to be
done uh so
um second effort though is like let's
say we're going to be pragmatics we also
know that you know we do have good
starting points we have things like
Alpha fold um esm fold that are uh kind
of quite quite effective structure
predictors they they're you know in fact
you know structures are never static you
know kind of in in the body in the test
tube even when they're Frozen They're
they're wiggling in this kind of
distribution of States described by the
boltzman distribution um and so things
like ala fold are in a sense like a
modal EST like a point estimate of kind
of what that distribution is so one idea
um is well when we think about the
fusion models what we're really learning
is like often times modern diffusion
models are kind of reduced to a
regression problem right we want to
learn like a posterior optimal denoiser
of kind of show me noisy thing it kind
of noise State uh somewhere along this
trajectory give me uh estimator kind of
what's the average thing that where I
came from to have produced that and
posterior average sense so um the nice
thing is like if you already have a
model that's trying to be a point
estimator of where you're going to land
that's actually a great starting point
to essentially fine-tune from a kind of
Point estimator into a diffusion model
so theide idea here is essentially take
off the shelf out fold or esm fold and
then we can essentially you know um in
this case they use a flow matching
framework I mean I think it's like an
aine transform of of learning whether
you're learning a denoiser or kind of a
flow something that's predicting flow
they're just related to each other by
aine and transforms so pretty similar
idea but then um in this case we just uh
we can add augment the training data
with some noise and then uh just
fine-tune our original Point estimator
as kind of one of these noise whereare
uh regressors doesn't actually take a
lot of training and what they're already
seeing is kind of this can can do useful
things kind of out of the gates so uh in
this case basically what you see here
it's like Precision recall precisions
like um do my samples look like the data
and then re uh recalls kind of like do
the data look like my samples and then
diversities just kind of do the data
look like each other um or do they look
unlike each other so so to speak there
all of those questions are like measured
by some Metric that compares protein
structures um so what you see here is
kind of I mean the the point estimators
like ala fold maybe has the best
Precision but we can actually add a
substantial amount of diversity by doing
a little bit of fine-tuning uh without
like uh paying too much of a cost for
kind of precision recall tradeoffs um so
uh and you can also augment these with
MD data and they're starting to show
that you can can begin to see these
these uh these kind of ensembles making
contact with the the MD data um in ways
that are way different than like there
used to be kind of hacky ways folks
would try to add diversity into Alpha
fold by let's say kind of randomizing
its inputs like uh it has some extra
auxiliary inputs you randomize them if
you poke it on the front end it kind of
gets diversity on the back end but this
is like a principled way we can kind of
diff diffusion or or flow matching
augment uh a kind of otherwise
deterministic predictor so um that this
is like this section was shorter but I
kind of I feel like these are all very
interesting directions where kind of a
lot of generative modeling ideas kind of
there's a lot of algorithmic development
to be done and kind of you know we're
still in very early days basically we
can either add a little bit of noise
onto um to uh pre-existing pointwise
folding models we can kind of let's say
amortize local regions of uh of of an
energy landscape with these kind of
learned uh these these learned flow
surrogate models but like really where
we want to be is kind of just have a
magic machine that you know press a
button and it can it spit out like what
will come from an expensive MD
simulation so that's kind of I think
there's tons of work to do there if that
these kinds of things that are of
interest to you all so maybe I can yeah
be happy to take uh questions in that
middle part too before we go into the
you know final section yeah John maybe
maybe I'll start with a question um when
you learn the energy function
right to approximate to
physics what's the intuition is the
intuition that the Learned energy
function would be smoother hence you can
take larger time steps on it in one go
or can you say a bit more of why is the
learn energy function helpful given you
have a ground
truth oh sorry um I think so one thing
that you mentioned there touches on
something that I didn't cover uh which
I'll come back to you but I I probably
didn't characterize it so are talking
about the these kind of Light Flow
approaches yeah so a sense like this
energy here is the ground truth energy
so it's purely like let's distill the
ground truth energy and implied uh
ground truth distribution into a c into
a flow model uh so yes you could say
that new flow model has a kind of
implied density which has an implied
energy but in fact we are annoyed by
that and we try to get rid of that with
important sampling but kind of
essentially there's no energy learning
here it's literally just can we take
known the ground truth energy and bake
it into a flow model I see and then the
sampling is free because sampling from
flow models I mean not free but it's
very cheap um yeah exactly so if you
have like complicated statistics you
need to compute you now have like
replaced running uh mcmc or something
with kind of uh a flow training
process interesting and so now you don't
run simulation anymore you just directly
sample from the flow and that's your
comes from the right distribution got it
yeah I missed that part thank you no
sorry yeah I was definitely go going
quick so um good yeah helpful
clarification and I would say it's kind
of like that's the idea it's still like
you have currently to get these working
you have to like warm start it with
some kind of pre-made uh samples from
the ground truth distribution to even
kind of stabilize the flow training uh
but uh kind of an interesting idea for
kind of amortising uh
sampling go for it so um the first slide
in your this section you mentioned
something about like 400 million
steps right and I I wonder do we have
like Theory people have come up with
some theoretical guarantee that these
problems are harm and there are no
shortcuts
I'm not sure if there is any Theory over
with that or
not are you aware of this I think I I
might have like missed a
couple lost a couple words from mic um
but I think the question was basically
around like what what kind of theory
around hardness of these problems does
or doesn't exist there are some problems
that theoretically hard to protect like
SAR automat automata that given initial
conditions you cannot predict the
outcome at least in in a shortcut way so
I wonder if there is a shortcut in this
problem too oh or not
sorry yes um so this is definitely out
of my depth like kind of the um uh
hardness and like theoretical computer
science side of kind of these problems
there are like folklore there there are
um definitely people like done like in
cute toy problem regime shown like
certain NP hard reductions on like
certain protein folding or kind of other
problems that involve like sampling from
hard energy function like you can
definitely concoct energy functions that
are hard to optimize I think another
question that comes up though is like uh
is the typical set of things we
encounter in nature like remotely like
that like actually maybe there's a lot
of kind of
cooperativity or kind of um Collective
effect structure in the actual energy
functions see in the world that make
them kind of not pathologically hard to
sample for so I think like another kind
of question people keep coming up with
is like yes no definitely we can
concoct uh examples and maybe even on
like this exact you know you know some
of these exact force fields that like
come from chemistry like we could like
kind of say you know in a worst case
scenario they can be hard but like
another question is like from a from the
point of view of can we approximate them
with generators like does that even
matter if the kind of typical problems
we encounter uh in nature might have
like kind of some extra structure we can
leverage in them
and that actually reminds me of I think
Peter you uh mentioned kind of
smoothness is smoothness helpful so I
did want to I forgot to mention it here
but I mean I think an obvious like one
reason that this training is really hard
is kind of this landscape that the kind
of ground truth we're trying to distill
into the flow is extremely rugged and
bumpy but the problem is and so like
gradient information or sample
information that we get on that is
extremely local and it does not really
help train kind of our our distillation
of the landscape at all but you can
imagine like the idea of diffusion or
these models that kind of add what like
not just temperature but let's say like
actual smoothing to the landscape um
would start to have let's say like
nonlocal information being learned so
there are I didn't put them in here but
there are some interesting papers where
people are trying to think could you
kind of augment uh build like kind of
augmented samp State spaces or Samplers
of ground truth energy functions but
where you kind of augment the ground Tru
thing with these diffusion like
processes and then you know add in the
kind of typical diffusion Machinery to
then be able to draw samples so I just I
your point about smoothness earlier was
uh kind of very I think connected to
that couple more questions here but let
me first ask a followup to the to the
last question John it it seems like part
of what you're saying is I mean if I'm
hearing it correctly maybe the problem
should cannot be hard because Nature has
to solve it at all times and
consistently or we we wouldn't be here
right if it's a problem with too many
local Optima then it's it seems like
most of us would like fall into the
wrong State quickly and wouldn't
function and so I wonder if maybe I mean
is there I
mean is there possibly something missing
from how this is formulated right now
and and I don't know much about this but
you can imagine the way a protein is
transcribed from RNA that there is
essentially an RNA molecule there and
maybe the RNA molecule affects the
Dynamics or maybe the solution of water
or salty water or whatever the protein
is in
somehow makes it a better behaved energy
landscape and if willing to simulate
more actually it becomes easier
somehow meaning willing to simulate more
molecules around the protein maybe the
actual Dynamics becomes
easier I think like absolutely I think
that's a that's a a thought and theme
that I think a lot of people hold uh
kind of as they think about the space
and then like in terms of how to action
on it I guess people are always trying
to come up with inductive biases that
like well you know let's say if it is co
transational folding like the RNA point
or if it is let's say that there's kind
of a local cooperativity to folding
there's some kind of theory on this from
the protein Science World kind of that
let's say local structures that are
let's say nearby in the linear quence
form faster and earlier than the than
the kind of long range ones in a kind of
downhill tumbling way uh you I mean
right now people are doing things like
try to bake those biases into networks
uh and finding that it does make a
difference I'll actually kind of cover
that a little bit in the in the last
section but I think yeah I think it's
kind of that is that seems very true and
I think the kind of current way people
are leveraging is with uh architecture
and inductive
bias got it the question yeah yeah so
you said that actually you want to come
to the mic because I think John had a
hard time hearing the previous question
oh yeah sure are you I think I can hear
but I
mean yeah
yeah I I'll project louder yeah so you
said that flows are helpful because they
help you deal with noisy data and
regularization but like in class we saw
that like flows aren't as popular right
now for like vision and language data so
do you think the flow model was helpful
here due to the fact that your data can
be captured in a principled way with
like this folzman
distribution I think the reason flows
were helpful here is that um they allow
you to do things like these kale
divergences
calculation uh or get good estimators of
kale Divergence kind of more easily than
at least kind of other approaches people
were doing at the time uh so like I can
just draw samples and then like push
like back propagate the truth energy
through the differentiable flow get you
know forces on that and then this other
term I just get because I have that um
um because of the restricted
architecture that lets me get the kind
of log de Jacobian term so I think it
was more like they were uh convenient
for the building statistical estimators
I think they're actually really
inconvenient because the like
architecture restrictions on on them and
also just the kind of extra training
dynamics of these like Oban terms uh
make them just really like hard to kind
of take advantage of the problem fully
like the field and protein like there's
kind of we have like mature ideas in the
protein modeling field of like what are
good neural networks to model these data
but kind of when you have to do like
real MVP or kind of one of those flow
things you have to sacrifice a lot of
aspects of the
model um so I yeah it's kind of probably
more because of just it was analytically
convenient that Mak sense I have a
question question so in this section um
you started talking about inference um
and I thought that was interesting
because usually within this field we
talk we think a lot about prediction so
I'm curious about like what sorts of
strategies or tools are used um in in
theer science um either for the genetics
part or for this section that helps us
understand like the conditional
distribution and the marginal
distributions that you were discussing
in the
beginning yeah um um well I mean I'm not
sure I would actually have a good answer
on like the different like the
distinction between inference and
prediction or like I think you know
certain kinds of inference can can have
be Rel can give you certain kinds of
predictions uh oh man um well yeah I
don't know if I have a maybe because I'm
not understanding the question like
there's a clean answer I think we use
inference all over the place like I
think kind of back here I mentioned we
use like Markov random Fields uh in part
we do that because we can compute
conditionals really easily and in
protein design let's say if we have a
generative model like we frequently have
a case where we have a generative model
we trained it one way but when we do
design we want to do compute clamped
conditionals for example I'm going to
clamp this part of the protein if you
like imagine or an image infilling task
like clamp and infill and so like that
requires kind of a lot of these kind of
conditional inference Machinery um all
of these might have relevance for kind
of like Computing marginals and
different cases um I don't know if
that's getting a your question but uh
yeah you the toolbox of inference is
useful a
lot last question for this section and
then we'll continue yeah go for it I
just want to ask like what's the order
of data required train the flow model
like because you're bottleneck by the
amount of energy evaluations you can do
right so is it also 400 million points
you need to train the flow model on
or oh no yeah you definitely I mean the
thing about uh yes you do not in any
approach that I've seen where people are
doing so this you know I gave you two
vignettes this field of kind of machine
learning for accelerating molecular
simulation really huge there are a lot
of ideas but um you never train on the
400 million time steps like you you
don't have to do that because the
samples are just insanely autocorrelated
like unfortunately it has to do with
kind of the curvature of the ground
truth energy function that is why we
kind of have to take this incredibly
Small Time step like the highest
frequency fluctuations in the system
kind of are are the thing that set the
kind of the learning rate so to speak uh
but uh but definitely like they're so
autocorrelated that sometimes you have
to do tens or hundreds of thousands of
steps before you've kind of moved a
meaningfully far away enough uh to kind
of get statistical to kind of even just
get not even statistical Independence
but just kind of enough new information
so I think people do tons of thinning
before they training and any of these
kinds of in the loop
approaches thank you John
Let's yeah you have to do the like you
have to do the energy evaluations in
your s simulation Hardware sorry I
interrupted you there Peter I was just
saying let's start with part three to
make sure we have enough time for it
sure thing okay so this last part is
maybe kind of the more by the book of
you know today's uh generative models in
the age of kind of uh Dolly and imagine
and Sora and kind of all the other
things that we're seeing uh appearing
all the time kind of can we just in
molecular engineering this idea could
one day if just you have a molecule what
you want to make can you walk in and say
uh here's my specifications of what I
want and then a system can immediately
synthesize like an answer and uh and
then you know we can make it uh a crazy
thing about proteins is that actually
now we have uh silicon based ways to
just print DNA so you know you could and
very you know a matter of days or
probably not too far from now like hours
just go from a completely insilico
generated thing to a physical nanom
machine in the real world um so that's
the dream so that's the last part here
um proteins have kind of alluded to them
so far you're unfortunately kind of have
to hear about proteins from three
different angles today um so you
probably like this is known proteins are
are they're like they're the doers of
the cell they're Nano machines they can
solve all kinds of problems uh we
they're genetically encoded and they're
easy to make so but they're nanom
machines when we think of nanom like
kind of LGE large small scales
technologies have been transformative
for people maybe we think of the
semiconductor industry but like when you
make let's say uh you know an h100 or
whatever like you have to use one of
these crazy asml $200 million machines
uh to S to kind of control things on
that level and the amazing thing about
proteins is they're made by bacteria and
the technology to manufactur is
literally like the same technology that
we use to make like beer uh so once you
have the DNA and you've put it into
bacteria they they can manufacture
nanotechnology for you kind of uh kind
of at like a commodity rates and scales
so but the interesting thing is so so
far we talked basically about you know
genetics which is about looking at
proteins and other biomolecules and DNA
that existed in the past and then
simulation which is also kind of just
under understanding what proteins we've
already seen do but like a big question
is like what are all the you know Earth
has only been around and life on Earth
has only been around for a few billion
years like but protein Mo molecular
space like how much of that have we even
touched in the history of all of life on
Earth and like what else is out there
like what else could even just our own
wetwear do if if like we we hijacked it
or kind of uh and tried to build more
things the interesting thing is like
actually almost all of the industrially
relevant proteins that you see today are
are just edits they just with something
we already had and we make some
mutations to it it's been incredibly
productive and valuable so like a lot of
um Nobel Prize Franc Arnold um a lot of
the most important proteins in Industry
are kind of enzymes that do complicated
chemistry but the Workhorse for that
really has been to take Natural enzymes
like the kind of things sometimes we
find in our liver that like break up uh
kind of toxins or something and then
like hijacking those editing them to do
new things and similarly some of the
most impactful protein based drugs that
we use in in cancer uh and infectious
disease and other things they're all
like basically we take human or animal
antibodies and we edit them a little bit
and kind of this is the vast majority of
everything in industry is like not from
scratch um and actually if you look at
this uh like most of the proteins got
invented three billion years ago so
don't need to like look in this too much
but it's just like fun aside um maybe
also makes us think why the likelihood
stuff was weird in the beginning but
basically like this is an axis you know
know the the the y- axis here is
billions of years so all the proteins
kind of this is models based on phog
genomics kind of estimates when did
genes get invented like you'll see the
red is like when the proteins got
invented they all get invented like
three billion years ago and then it's
kind of mainly been copy paste and edit
that nature done so it's kind of like uh
this is oversimplification but Earth
invented a bunch of useful proteins and
then we've be able to kind of evolution
has been able to get by the past few
billion years kind of just with that
kind of iterating copy pasting that
existing repertoire so but now in the AG
of these kind of amazing generative
models that we're seeing kind of in all
kinds of modalities it's a really
interesting question could we like
escape this entrenchment like where uh
we kind of have to keep editing things
that already exist um can we can we get
past it I mean another question is like
why was nature so entrapped for a few
billion years part of the reason is
because these are really hard to kind of
stick the landing on out of the blue
proteins have a lot of complex con
strengths over a lot of length scales
down to like the width of an atom to you
know maybe a thousand times that um and
it all kind of just needs to be right
and if you get one thing wrong it won't
work at all so it's kind of quite hard
to stumble into functional proteins but
once you have them there are actually
many many ways you can edit them which
will preserve function so just just
because I'm going to show a few protein
pictures um like this is visual like you
often see these things they just look
kind of like cart ribbons or something
but what the what the ribbon diagrams or
the these cartoons are conting is that
they're the actual underlying complex
bonding structure that's happening in
the protein so you'll kind of see these
like little there's this chemical
structure of the protein backbone and
then there's these Dash lines those are
hydrogen bonds and like they need to be
right to kind of within like less than
the width of an atom like down to an
angstrom and you kind of uh you you
can't like have you know a nois like a
noisy image uh kind of can still be
ially a meaningful image uh but a noisy
protein and that is kind of broken so so
it's kind of very finicky okay so but
then again like if I try to like start
telling the story that like proteins are
special in some ways I feel like we'll
get laughed at by image generative
modeling because like it's also like the
level of the amount of kind of pixel
level and semantic constraints in like
modern image generation are absolutely
insane so it's not like it's not like
this is harder than images it's just
maybe kind of like uh data bear
and kind of uh the challenge to just get
it all working so how can we know catch
up to the amazing things that have been
happening kind of in other parts of
generative modeling world and see that
with proteins so well okay so this whole
area of inventing new proteins from
scratch it's called like computational
protein design or denova protein design
it's been around for a long time there's
been a lot of successes the classic ways
where you had this kind of semi physical
handcrafted energy function uh and you
would you would kind of just do iterated
kind tinkering and like deep you know
each PhD would be like someone writing
deeply custom like sampler code that
like sticks things together and then
most of them wouldn't work and then some
of them would randomly work and then
that that would be a great outcome but
it's kind of not robust and very kind of
complex steep finicky um so um you know
still the field made progress but it's
not kind of just like a ask for
something get a protein back kind of
question and then uh what I wanted to
end here today um and I'll try to get
through this part like so we get like at
least five minutes for questions um is
like just something you may have already
heard like I think it's kind of eaten up
like uh let's say like Workshop
bandwidth at a lot of the big ml
conferences um but like basically
generative modeling haset ate the
protein design field it is like this was
the like way everything was done you
know maybe four years ago or so and just
there's been a complete flip around all
the like leading labs and everyone it's
just it's all neural networks now
from kind of all sides both sides it's
kind of like if I know a structure and I
want to make a sequence to it or if I
just want to invent everything from
scratch it's kind of all generative
models lots of work definitely can't go
into all of it so I'll tell you about
what kind of we do here uh this company
I'm at called generate now um we we were
involved in kind of one of the there's
been a bunch of really cool diffusion
models kind of thinking about how you
make backbones or kind of whole protein
complexes and how you condition them in
interesting ways I'll tell you a little
bit about something we did here and make
sure we have time time for questions so
good news I heard someone asking
diffusion questions I mean uh this being
Peter's class I'm sure you all hear you
know no diffusion models well as um so
hopefully this is kind of not uh this
part is is very familiar um but right
we're kind of augmenting the data with
the noising process we're learning this
kind of posterior uh kind of where did I
come from estimator or you know flow or
score or whatever um and then kind of
doing that we can parameterize kind of a
reverse process uh right so earlier
there was a question about like how can
we build in stuff we know about proteins
that maybe take advantage of like the
fact that what makes it easier for
nature and also build a models um I'll
talk about a little bit like how we
build inductive bias uh um so the um
kind of one one thing we found like what
are useful properties of a generative
model in this field one is yeah have
inductive biases be efficient and kind
of take advantage of what we know about
the field other is have likelihoods
because as we saw like likelihoods can
be useful in science much in the same
way that they tell you useful things
about genetics
they can tell you things about molecules
like what's stable or not what's stable
mutation or not and then most
importantly is like how do you build a
kind of controllable ecosystem so um I
think in the interest of time like I
mean people talk about of sub quadratic
models all the time everybody's trying
to figure out you know how people are
doing long context and kind of the
latest llms or maybe you can't afford to
do quadratic if you have good enough
Hardware
implementations uh but like many things
is also a question and proteins like if
every atom in a molecular system really
had to be able to talk to every other
atom in the molecular system like
physics wouldn't work or kind of nothing
would happen on time like physics is in
a hash function it takes advantage of
statistical structure when we do
physical simulations of the universe you
don't have to calculate like the
specific gravity between like Earth and
a galaxy far away you can do like Point
approximations and build more n log kind
of things and that's what are important
ideas there so we did that kind of with
our the underlying like kind of
attention or graph structure inside of
these neural networks um actually it's
like I think similar there was like a
big bird paper or something sorry can I
okay yeah um so uh we're basically just
add in random long-range context it's
that because we know the kind of rough
influence structure that essentially we
want this n log n type scaling you can
actually create like a scaling law um
with certain properties point is just
it's sparse but kind of has more local
connectivity that kind of dose in not
super important uh we just do correlated
diffusion uh building in some known kind
of statistical structure with protein
chains so instead of just like it being
a white noise gas we can we can build in
structure like that these are chains and
that they kind of like to pack to a
certain density and you can bake that
into the covariant structure of the
diffusion uh here's what the full model
looks like you know we just have a diff
like a kind of noising process but it
has a statistical structure so it kind
of turns our our original protein
structure into this kind of random
collapsed glob system and then we have
like a neural network that kind of uses
the sparse connectivity to try to and
some other stuff to like estimate a best
uh you know a best uh posterior mean of
kind of where did this structure come
from okay and then good news it has a
scalable architecture just doing the
diffusion thing um this is kind of like
maybe even like two years ago this was
kind of weird we're all uh like RS came
out at the same time one from the baker
lab RF diffusion and kind of it was that
moment which I think has happened in a
lot of fields where kind of like oh you
can oh you can spit out whole protein
complexes now so what you're seeing here
is this is also at the level of
complexes so when I mentioned
interactions earlier um each color here
is a separate molecule so we're also
modeling The Joint distribution over
collections of molecules which would
allow us to for example design like a
drug that would bind to a particular
side if we do it as a conditional thing
or kind of build these more complex
systems um I think I'm going to skip the
likelihood thing we have like a low
temperature sampler and when you lower
temperature structure becomes stronger
there I mean have been other there's
lots of ideas on how to do good
diffusion Samplers maybe the important
takeaway though is like conditional
Generation Um this point uh there's lots
of kinds of things we get asked to do so
we're kind of protein design company we
like have to um we work with Partners or
own things and then kind of left and
we'll say I need a protein that's going
to interact with X thing or or kind of
have some certain function and so kind
of really but it's changing all the time
so really what we kind of want is like a
language with which we could express
these constraints and then transfer that
or convert that into a conditioning
program in a sense that can like drive a
diffusion process so that's kind of and
also it's just easier to organize like
if you have these Foundation models you
train and then you have lots of
scientists working on different
conditioner blocks then we could
potentially compose them in ways to kind
of do all the things you want to do
there's lots of different things you
could want to do with proteins like get
proteins that symmetrize into large
complexes like a viral particle or a
delivery vehicle or um maybe you want to
infill like you want make a binder I
want to infill the part that binds or if
I want to kind of take the useful part
of one protein and shove it in another
protein I could kind of grab that and do
conditional sampling and out fill the
rest of the protein maybe I actually
just want to make shapes uh because I
have some hypothesis about how a certain
shape will have a certain function and
also just because it's probably where
the field is going and we start to like
do text condition generation too um you
know I think it's still a ways off but
like uh natural language interfaces are
obviously becoming a big part of this uh
this is kind of um some ideas on how
you're building conditioning uh um I
want to make sure yeah that we can get
to the point but also get to the punch
line I mean uh okay so when normally
when we do diffusion sampling there's a
lot of different ways of casting know
continuous time versus discreet time
score based approaches or kind of more
variational style um here we're kind of
if you bear with me we're like in the
continuous time score based picture so
it's the score the score is is the
gradient of something which what's that
thing is it's the diffusion energy so
kind of in the most General sense when
we sample from diffusion models with uh
these things you there's kind of an
underlying energy function whose
gradient is being used to drive sampling
process um and uh there's a couple
different kinds of ways you can think
about conditioning so there's let's say
soft constraints which are things like
classifier guidance where we want to
kind of tilt the score function with
auxiliary gradients that come from like
some other model but there's also hard
constraints like maybe if Ben is isting
next I know there's like the dream
Fusion stuff if any of you seen that
where you kind of actually try to back
propagate through a rigid
parameterization to the diffusion to
kind of force your diffusion model into
a fixed hard constraint parameterization
and so you could kind of roughly think
of one of these things is like an energy
adjustment where we're kind of tilting
the diffusion energy and another one is
a state transformation like there's an
underlying state that would parameterize
a system like let's say a Nerf or a 3D
system or something else and then we
kind of like in some ways we just want
to kind of do sampling where we uh kind
of account for these
other perations of of energy or
conditioning so basically I'm I'm
basically making the picture more
complicated to be able to add in more
options um but you know if if you delete
this term where the identity if you make
the zero and if you make these terms
down here one we're kind of doing the
standard reverse diffusion thing as we
add in like an energy term it could be
classifier guidance as we add in a stain
transform we could be doing hard
constraints and then what we're doing
that here is like as soon as we turb the
system we're no longer in the
non-equilibrium diffusion picture where
you can kind of just reverse things and
it all works you actually have to pay a
sampling price to kind of re-equilibrate
to whatever conditioning perturbations
you're doing so um you know there's not
a ton of time and I want to make sure
like kind of stick The Landing with a
little more time for final questions um
but uh I'll just I'll say is like you
can we were able to find at least this
large library of different conditioning
things could all be casting this
framework of essentially kind of state
Andor energy transformations So like um
you could kind of think of it like it's
really just using standard uh mcmc stuff
where like how do you do constrained
mcmc one thing is you just
reparameterize your system uh your
constrained system to unconstrained
coordinates okay well then that
corresponds to like having some uh
transform the implements the the
constraints and then you know you have
to kind of adjust the energy by a change
of Vari change of volume term uh
similarly if you have like a hard
constraint that's just like a linear
projection uh that is actually just like
a simple linear transform of this thing
um and this is all super pytorch
friendly you just kind of instead of
your normal score function that you plug
into diffusion you just take the
gradient of this whole object and pull
the pull the gradients back to the
unconstrained parameterization and kind
of implement scoring because the inputs
and outputs of these like and UT
transforms are the same type we can also
their blocks we can stack them so now if
I have like oh I have you know a
symmetry constraint but I also want to
kind of add this classifier guidance on
top of it I can just start stacking
these these modules together and kind of
do compositional programming of
molecules so anyway uh last section show
you some proteins so yeah okay you do
all this stuff and now we can make you
know just uh in a few like a couple
minutes or sometimes less than a minute
uh these large like molecular systems on
command we can do infilling we can do
out filling um I mean the big question
is is it real so first thing you can do
to ask about realness it's really hard
the field still kind of suffers from not
having good in celic metrics to know if
proteins work one kind of imperfect but
useful starting point is just to try to
see well we use this totally un related
diffusion model to generate a structure
over here let's like take Alpha fold or
esm fold or some program that was kind
of trained totally separately different
architecture thing does it at least
agree that like this thing you've
proposed will refold into what you say
it should be um so you can do this like
you can get symmetry to refold you can
get um uh kind of infilling out filling
stuff to refold we actually got um The
esm Fold model from meta to make the
alphabet um so we're essentially like
conditioning on volumetric densities to
get uh
shape designing sequence just a linear
sequence of uh you know amino acids
that's supposed to encode that shape and
then we shoot it over to esm fold and
sure enough it like refolds into the
shape and these I like the nice thing
about these is like yeah the function of
them is less clear but one thing we can
be sure is like these do not exist in
nature so like at least all of the
models that are out there right now are
seeming to think yeah like these seem
possible these seem like reasonable
proteins um supposedly we've talked you
know there are some people we've heard
who are who are interested in making
these this is maybe not like our first
uh kind of go to market drug thing but
like it's like just like if you lower
the cost of generation and kind of
meanwhile protein synthesis getting
easier like soon we'll just be able to
kind of make stuff all the time um so on
and so forth but you know we also made
them in the lab uh and what we saw is
that kind of we started with just
unconditional stuff and one thing we did
is when we designed this experiment we
actually didn't uh didn't require that
they had to refold by the out fold or
other things we're just let's just take
the raw model output maybe filtered by
likelihood um and just send them to the
lab and uh kind so actually they look
kind of ugly they're kind of weird
proteins but we like were proud that
they were kind of you know the spicy
random unconditional samples that you
know you normally bury in your
supplement uh and we got like a lot of
them expressed and in bacteria and they
they looked good and happy they're kind
of there's certain biophysical
properties you can measure that kind of
tell you roughly if the structure is
kind of has the right um these like
helices or or sheets in it we also were
able to Crystal a few of them and it was
pretty cool so like the very first one
uh was like dead on to like within the
width of an atom so like one angstrom is
the width of an atom and uh even though
when you fold this without Alpha Fold It
kind of doesn't fold right so this is
another thing is just it's a proposal
mechanism we have these imperfect things
I mean esm fold is able to fold it I
mean I this is I don't want to like get
the wrong conclusion from that but uh so
the point is like we now have this
proposal mechanism we can turn these
proposals into DNA put them in the real
world and just start seeing you know you
know we're going from digital to
physical and it's kind of I think one of
the first generative model opportunities
for that um and then you know this is
kind of old now but a lots happening you
can also read a bunch of those other
papers I mentioned earlier it's a really
fast moving field new things every week
but I think people are really excited
because there's kind of a lot of uh you
know a lot to do with this so um I mean
I'm glad we at least got to have time
for questions in the first two um
related to this but you know thanks for
time uh maybe I probably have time for
like one or two
now well let's first thank
John and I'll end with the thought of
just like you know I don't know like
exactly where you all are coming from
but at least like kind of sometimes
there's like this question should we
like yes scaling is important we all
have to figure out how to scale but I
still think you know kind of like loan
loan actor new methods ideas there's
just so much you can do in this space
and like algorithms matter so uh
um just want to end on that
that thank you John
questions hi John thanks for the great
talk um the question I have is it seems
like one of the main aspiration of the
field of design is being able to
condition on arbitrary new Target
functions like AC rinding able to
generate sequences that are readily
synthesizable so I'm wondering what if
you have any thoughts on the directions
opportunities and you know directions
and being able to leverage these asset
label DMS data and then building gener
models on say directly all sequences
continuous
or yeah um so I think there are a few
parts to that first absolutely the like
dream is kind of that like eventually
we'll just have models or systems of
models where kind of any function you
can ask for is close to the types of
functions that let's say biologists that
we work with or kind of uh people who
focus on medicine like asor we can just
and as close to the way human would
describe it tell our systems and then
they can kind of do all the detail work
and give us and what we really care
about at the end of the day which is
sequences um that we can then go and
synthesize the nice thing about
sequences is they're all synthesizable
um for the like generally speaking
because it's you kind of as long as
you're in the linear sequence you know
de uh natural amino acid vocabulary it's
all technically valid whether it will
kind of work um in the lab you know
depends on lots of other things um and
some of that stuff depends on kind of
measurements that you get from like
large scale let's say sets of
sequences and kind of associated labeled
properties like will it be stable or
kind of aggregate with other things and
and of us and you know lots of people
are kind of collecting these data at
scale um and some of it only exists like
let's say with labeled sequences so I
think maybe
um the kind of the dream is you need a
system that can kind of think about
protein in all these different ways
about it sequence about its structure
and most importantly about its function
and kind of Meet the constraints in
their most natural form so sometimes
that'll be sequence constraint sometimes
that'll be a function constraint
sometimes it'll be a structure
constraint and kind of uh do all the
other stuff that needs to be done um so
that looks like joint models uh joint
models that also think about
function uh and kind of just all the
different ways you might consider
inference and sampling and that that
picture conditioning on one doing the
other maybe one one last question if
there's more
questions we already asked a lot of
questions so how about we wrap up here
because we're also Up Against Time John
thank you so much
again well awesome thank you all for
your time um and you sounds like a very
cool talk here and store for next